they are the three lionesses pride of
England with mains longer than the
dominant males and with a hunger to go
further than the toothless Three Lions
in South Africa after the FAA's recent
ugly encounter with FIFA Football could
do with a shot of the beautiful game and
in world cup host country Germany the
women's game in a men's magazine is
front-page news isn't any of their main
main squad you know I was just a tad
surprised it's not something that
personally I would want to do without
seeing I'm sure the players wouldn't
want to do it for a start Sepp Blatter
at least would probably approve the FIFA
president famously once called for women
to play football in tighter shorts I
don't mind to be honest tight shorts but
I think we need to be a fine line
between us playing football and then
dressing up like that footballers not
just because of women I mean we're all
talented and we're technically as good
as the men even other games not as quick
as the men forever I think we've
obviously I respect ourselves and where
the correct and it's all about looking
for a topsy display Gordon
representative country are you clubs or
that's amazing anyone offended by mr.
Blatter then no it's just not possible
the only strip on England's mind is the
one they'll be wearing in Germany
how they would love to avenge the male 3
Lions world cup mauling by the Germans
in bloom Fontaine Chris gutter sky news